she even emailed us last night she goes
you guys look so awkward on the red
carpet
oh yeah Ashton Kutcher's wife Mila Kunis
totally roasts Reese Witherspoon's
awkward photos with her hubby I think
it's funny the now viral pics were taken
as Reece and Ashton promoted their new
Netflix rom-com your place or mine 20
years of friendship can you believe it
how do you still speak to me do you
remember the first night we met
foreign
[Music]
and while posing with each other on red
carpets first in a photo call and then
at the Los Angeles Premiere fans pointed
out how awkward Ashton and Rhys were
standing and someone else who noticed
Mila you were friends with Mila uh I'm
better friends with Mila because I'd
known her for a very long time every
time like he'd wear a funny outfit I'd
text me I'll be like what is he wearing
she even emailed us last night she goes
you guys look so awkward on the red
carpet why are you just not anyway well
Mila Reese and Ashton definitely got the
memo now the pair looked like besties at
a New York swinging for the film I'm
everybody's best friend I love people
yeah and those picks had fans also
theorizing the two co-stars didn't get
along but that couldn't be further from
the truth was that the big draw for you
to return to this genre was that we need
kind of more of this levity it was that
it was the idea of working with the
queen wait what is all this Peter's not
interested in me like that is he
I feel like we should see what you and I
could be thank you
this is a minor setback right all you
have to do is take a chance I don't take
chances I mean did working with Ashton
for the first time live up to your
expectations Reese I mean it was so fun
in this perfect movie we both had equal
parts if that's a big piece of it too I
think a lot of rom-coms don't know how
to balance yeah and this one was just a
50 50 movie and so we both felt
responsible for making it funny and
better and endearing and real and
grounded and so I think it was just and
I'm so glad it's on Netflix too because
I feel like it's just gonna be
everybody can see it
foreign